our depressive meds really good for our
heads and was tom cruise right when he
said those pills were a fright
a major review out of the university
college london found no convincing
evidence that low serotonin levels
caused depression casting doubt on the
use of antidepressants to treat it
what do they find more effective in
treating unhappiness
[Music]
[Applause]
wow i was like almost dead there for a
moment which leaves me with one just one
question
was tom cruise actually right all along
remember this here we are today
where i talk out against drugs
and psychiatric abuses of electric
shocking people
okay against their will of drugging
children with them not knowing i
understand there's abuse of all of these
things now you see here's the problem
you don't know the history of psychiatry
i do all it does is mask the problem do
you examine the possibility that these
things do work for some people maybe
there are too many kids on ritalin maybe
electric shock kids on riddling i'm just
saying but but aren't there examples
where it works
you don't even you're glib you don't
even know what ritalin is i agree with
tom the cure for depression is clearly
hundreds of millions of dollars in a
thriving movie career
but after being mocked for that opinion
about drugs could it be maybe this whole
time tom was right
although the royal college of
psychiatrists ooh fancy
urged people with depression to continue
taking their meds insisting
antidepressant drugs do in fact still
work which is more than you can say for
matt lauer
boom
cat in the uh in the green room you were
saying tom cruise is almost right on
everything and i should know i lived
with him for five years is that true
yeah a lot of people don't know that i
know
i know and it's amazing how you kept
that to yourself yeah yeah or telling
you anything again
so
it's not like he's totally right and
it's not like it's just we're only
talking about one chemical but there's
something interesting i mean you're
talking to a ritalin kid
you are
[Laughter]
i could not function in a classroom
setting yeah my behavior was so out of
control that whenever there was a
substitute teacher they would just
preemptively have me and do my work in
the principal's office
what would you do
what was your behavior just being myself
were you a yeller i was loud uh i
started like a chant of like no more
math and everyone joined in
and then they called my dad like you
were my your daughter was inciting a
riot and he made a great point he was
like she's five yeah
[Laughter]
but i'm actually i was on antidepres
i've been on most antidepressants uh but
i'm actually not on any right now and i
haven't been for over a year and just
i'm just one person right uh but for me
i realize that i feel differently when
i'm not on them in that i feel more like
bad and good which i'm cool with but
yeah
still still an amphetamine gal yeah good
for you
good for you
you know abd adhd combined type is no
joke yeah you know jimmy i think
whenever i look uh tom cruise i think
believes that you can just manage
reality right because like
therefore you can react you can manage
reality without chemistry all you have
to do is work your mind man yeah then he
jumps on your couch
[Laughter]
no but it's true tom cruise doesn't care
like to your point yeah he's on mission
impossible seven with a straight face
knowing they've pulled off the first six
it's clearly not impossible
[Laughter]
but like
mission fairly difficult but with any
luck you know what i mean
but he was right and think of how much
he was mocked for the last like 15 years
for contradicting the mainstream
narrative around drugs
you know and people like oh look at this
kook he's a loony which is no different
than what they do with you now with all
of these vaccines and boosters they
didn't have data to support those
diagnoses and they don't have data right
now to push a booster on your kids but
they do it and if you say you don't like
it they're like oh this guy's a
contrarian nut bag we shouldn't listen
to him the truth is we all knew there
was no chemical imbalance issue and if
you really want to stop and fight
depression don't root for the mets
anymore that's 80 percent of you i'd be
fine i have to take issue we've only
learned it's about one chemical yeah
it i mean i happen to believe it almost
everything's biological and you know
you are not welcome in the democratic
party yes i know
get them except excuse me except
biologically thanks for coming turf
thanks for coming
jk rowling in here
but there is something to be said that
they didn't do blood testing before they
you know prescribed this these drugs for
children i mean and tom cruise had a
point but i'm watching matt lauer i'm
thinking what about prescribing
antidepressants to all the women he
locked in his office
wow
wow
liz
and you know he could have used some
mood blockers matt lauer yes he could
but then i'm wondering when is tom
cruise going to weigh in on puberty
blockers for kids
that's actually a good point that's a
really good point because that's that's
far more out i mean going after uh going
after adults for making an adult
decision with antidepressants you know i
mean maybe it's brave but it's not as
brave as that and if you if you're
messing with kids yeah you know because
they're because they don't fit into that
that perfect gender hole or gender
square that's that's a travesty yeah it
is and by the way there's we see all
these drug commercials there's miles of
side effects right but no disclosure is
about the cost yeah
monetarily or otherwise getting it right
you're getting a little too close to our
advertising
warning gut-felt may cause
uncontrollable hilarity
sure and talk to your doctor about
watching a repeat chadwick okay let's
talk about the elephant in the room
scientology isn't that where a lot of
his
anti-pharmacology comes from in a way or
yeah i mean you know these these kind of
fringe religions do get some things
right occasionally like i think that
makes people better even though it
sounds funny
yeah yeah yeah yeah i i'm on the same
page i was prescribed while butrin wants
to quit smoking they used to do this yes
and when i went to pick it up the
farmers said oh by the way i got to tell
you uh sometimes the side effect is
suicidal thoughts yes and i said what he
goes i got to say that from the lawyer
and i said but it's anti-depressant and
he goes well sometimes depressed people
they want to kill themselves but they
have no energy and this gives them
energy
yeah and i swear god i took this for two
weeks
and two weeks into it i had this day and
i want to kill myself yeah and i didn't
know what was wrong with me
i was like and then i remember the
pharmacist i'm like it's this medication
amount stops never did he give you
something else no i didn't go back i'd
put in the garbage and you know what he
smoked and he's a happily he's a happy
smoker to this
there's a happy ending
all right we got to move on that we you
know no one tackles topics like we do
and call me tom
coming up the dumbest reason to
disappoint fans by far courtesy of pat
benatar
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else